now one important detail we'll need to
understand is how to get our image data
that our artists create into our game
for example the image filename also the
width and height of the image whether
it's been rotated at all and various
other pieces of information we might
need to know now to do this we're going
to use JSON which is a very lightweight
data interchange format that's based on
JavaScript object syntax now since it's
based on JavaScript it turns out that
it's really easy to use with JavaScript
much easier than say XML now here is an
example of a JavaScript object right
here
now this isn't JSON technically it is
the JavaScript object representation of
JSON that has been passed in the
difference between a JavaScript object
and JSON is that JSON is simply a string
that we can then parse to create a
JavaScript object and that's what we're
going to do here